we've going high fashion on an
affordable budget et exclusively on the
sets of cardi B's campaign shoot for her
second fashion Nova collection yeah is
boxing here guys we literally in the
middle of the desert we don't have no
service Kilis the singer kept it 100
even with all the bugs swarming our
shoot and she was on mama duty but
nothing in this world the I like more
the culture I do experience that mom
guilt you know cuz I right now my babies
with me oh she's here yeah she's here
but it makes me so sad sometimes because
it's like oh my gosh all that traveling
I know her sleeping schedule is getting
a little messed up and I know every
single time that she get on an airplane
it's all good into the landing she
started crying and I just be feeling so
sad because it's like I know the pain
you know where your ears pop I used to
be so sad and like sometimes I wake up
in the morning and I cheese in my bed
and I just want to cuddle with your
second fashion / collection how is this
one different than the first well this
one is different than the first because
we have more color and we have more
cutouts it's more fun it's more
summertime yeah but it also has that
matrix look that I like you know what
I'm say yes this one is very nice out
these colors are more like pastel colors
Black's of course like this is one of my
collection is this one your favorite
pieces yes this one of my favorite
assets it's very matrix
it's very matrix and it's sexy but it's
so classy and clean and I love it what
is going on with this set I mean there's
like a neon vibe we're in the middle of
like a vintage gas station there's a
Lambo over there did you have any say in
what this would look like yes like I
wanted like a neon jungle vintage desert
vibes no something different like you
know I know a lot of people like expect
like my collection to be like all girls
and a white screen and just showing the
outfit
I really want like to look like a really
high fashion campaign
I love how involved you are you're like
lady boss cardi B it's amazing yeah
your first collection sold out within
minutes yes is this one gonna beat that
record
I think so you want to know something
like this like I study what people
wanted I always read what some of the
pros and some of the cons of my last
collection even thought is it did well
and it's still doing well so it's just
like okay I'm gonna be a little bit more
fun
no more summertime vibes and I think we
were gonna like this one her new line
drops may 8th on fashion over.com
and of course cardi is throwing a party
habitual party with caught who is going
to be on that guest list well who is
performing she knows all about
performing yes of course I'm gonna
perform the city girls are gonna perform
Blueface is gonna perform yg is gonna
perform it's gonna be of a really big
party and I get really nervous when it
comes to party
that's why don't I celebrating my
birthday to me yes it's just because I
get I got anxiety
dude you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
totally and this is like sometimes I'd
be like oh my gosh my happen to people
don't come when I permit this but the
last fashionable party was such a big
success
and there were so many people that came
that it's just like this time we got a
bigger venue
we're flying people out were frying like
certain fans think I do certain things
that you might get flew out because I
just hope the people like my collection
I just want everything to be successful
can I tell you a secret
what did that everything that you touch
turns to gold so I think they're gonna
be okay
[Music]
what do you see is the future of the car
DB is brand I see everything I feel like
I can't accomplish everything in
anything so it is like whatever that I
can't set my mind to do him I could do
it whatever it is I feel like you're
such a trendsetter at this point like
people come to you for fashion
inspiration people come to you for
beauty inspiration when is the beauty
line coming soon
very
[Music]